[MUSIC PLAYING]
EMILY FORTUNA: We're excited
to have Daniel Galpin here
to tell us about Android news
from the Developer Keynote.
Hey, Daniel.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi, Dan.
So responsibility to our
users was the first core part
of the Android
developer keynote.
Now, how does this
relate to developers?
DANIEL GALPIN:
Well, users trusting
the platform is inherently
important to developers.
Downloading an app
is something we all
want users to feel
comfortable doing.
And that's why we've
given users more control
over their identity, around
how apps run in the background,
and about how apps share
storage with each other.
Now, these platform
changes ultimately
will require some apps to make
changes when they target queue,
but it's important for everyone
that we get this right.
EMILY FORTUNA: Tell me more
about how the Android studio
team focused on
quality improvements
for their latest release.
DANIEL GALPIN: Well, we're
always listening to developers.
And while new ID
features are great,
they don't mean
anything if your coding
is interrupted with the crashes
and performance problems.
So the team has fixed over
400 high-priority bugs
and made existing
features work better.
For example, we've
rewritten Instant Run
from the ground up with
a more solid foundation,
renaming it Apply Changes.
And developers can try all of
this today in the 3.5 beta.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, what's
the latest with Google Play?
DANIEL GALPIN: Ah, well,
it's all about app bundles.
And they make sure
the devices get
just the parts of
the APK they need,
which has turned into an
average of 20% smaller
downloads for users.
We've also recently launched the
1.0 release of dynamic feature
modules, which allows
apps to have even smaller
initial downloads
by choosing which
parts to download at launch.
And speaking of distribution,
we launched inline app updates
today, which provides
a standard way
to prompt users to update
their app when a new version is
available on Play.
EMILY FORTUNA: So what about
the updates to Android Jetpack?
DANIEL GALPIN: Well,
Android Jetpack
is another way
we've been investing
in developer productivity.
And CameraX is a huge step
forward in making it easier
for Android apps to
access the camera
and get consistent
behavior across devices.
We've also continued to
improve JetPack's architecture
components, having recently
released WorkManager
and the Navigation
Controller into stable,
adding enhanced RXJava
support for room,
adding Kotlin coroutine support
to room lifecycle and LiveData,
and adding Saved State
support to ViewModel.
And we're also continuing
to expand the architecture
components and
JetPack in general
to tackle new pain points,
including the new benchmarking
library.
Also the early source for a
new Kotlin First reactive UI
toolkit-- we're developing
the open JetPack Compose--
is now available.
So check it out, and
give us feedback.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Android development
is becoming Kotlin First.
Why is Kotlin First important?
DANIEL GALPIN: Well,
the world has spoken.
Kotlin is wildly popular.
Over 50% of pro Android
developers are using it,
and it means much less code
to type, test, and maintain.
Now of course, we're continuing
to invest in C++ and Java
programming language, and all
three choices remain great
options for Android development.
That being said, I'm excited
to see the reaction to our new
for Udacity course, "Developing
Android Apps in Kotlin."
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thanks
for stopping by, Daniel.
That was a lot of really
great information,
and we really appreciate it.
EMILY FORTUNA:
Thank you, Daniel.
DANIEL GALPIN:
Thank you, Timothy.
Thank you, Emily.
And I appreciate talking to you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]